solve for x and y we have two equations
with two unknowns negative three y plus
four x is equal to eleven and y plus two
x is equal to thirteen what we could do
is try to solve this using using
elimination maybe we can add these two
equations together to get some variables
to cancel out but if we just add y and
negative 3y those won't cancel out and
if we just had a 2x and 4x those won't
cancel out but maybe we can scale one of
these equations so that we will get some
cancellation if this y could somehow
become a 3y then 3y and negative 3i
would cancel out and so the easiest way
to turn this y into a 3y is to just
multiply this entire equation so we
don't actually change the information in
it to multiply this entire equation by
3.
so let's multiply both sides by 3. if we
multiply the left-hand side by 3 we get
3y
3y plus 6x to multiply every term by 3.
3y plus 6x is equal to 3 times 13 is 39.
so this equation and this equation are
the exact same equation i've just
multiplied both sides by 3 to go from
here to here so i multiplied by 3 and of
course we have this original equation up
here that negative 3y
plus 4x
is equal to 11. and now if we add the
left-hand side and the right-hand sides
of this equation something interesting
happens
the negative 3y and the positive 3y
cancel out that was the whole point
behind multiplying the second guy over
here by 3. so let's add them so if we
add these guys cancel out we have 4x
plus 6x is 10x and that is equal to 11
plus 39 which is 50 and then we can
divide both sides by 10
we get x is equal to 50 divided by 10
is 5. and then we can go substitute back
to solve for y
if x is 5 we could use the second
equation right over here we get y plus
2 times 5. i'll do it in that same color
2 times 5
is equal to 13 or
y plus 10 is equal to 13 we can subtract
10 from both sides
and we will get
y these cancel out y is equal to 3. so
our solution that we get for x and y is
that x is equal to five
and y is equal to three and we can
verify that it works in both equations
and this top equation let me do a new
color
negative three times three
plus 4 times 5
is this is negative 9 plus 20 which is
indeed equal to 11. so both of these
satisfy the first equation and then if
we take the second equation 3
plus
two times five
that's three plus ten that does indeed
equal thirteen so it definitely
satisfies both and i wanna be clear you
could have solved this with substitution
or you could have you could have changed
which equation you scale so that we get
different cancellations when we add or
different eliminations so another way
that we could have done this we could
have kept the first equation the same
negative 3y plus 4 x is equal to 11 but
maybe we want this 2x to cancel with
this 4x and the only way we could do
that is if this negative this 2x could
become a negative 4x and the way to get
from a 2x to a negative 4x is to
multiply it by negative 2. so let's
multiply this entire equation by
negative 2. so it'd become negative 2y
minus 4x
is equal to negative 26
and if we then add the two equations the
x's will cancel out you have negative 3y
minus 2y which is negative 5y
is equal to 11 minus 26 that's negative
15. now you can divide both sides by
negative 5.
and you get the negatives cancel out y
is equal to 3. so in this situation we
eliminated the x's first to solve for y
and then you could go back substitute
and solve for x you'll get x is equal to
5. the first time we did it we
eliminated the y's we scaled this
equation right here so that the y's
would cancel out and so we solved for
the x first and then substituted back
either way works you get x is equal to 5
y is equal to 3.